this is funny I didn't do it on this
trip but sometimes when I fly and I have
to fill out custom forms when it says
occupation I write firefighter that's
how I feel an entrepreneur is you're
always ready for another fire whether
it's two o'clock in the morning or 9:30
you have to be ready and I don't
struggle with that because I've been
practicing it my whole life which is why
I fear when people try to become
entrepreneurs because it's cool now I'm
worried about that because it's very
hard every single day I lose and unless
you're good at that you will not like
entrepreneurship you got your
perspective
[Applause]
[Music]
Brazil how are you good
so I'm gonna do about 40 minutes up here
then I'm gonna actually I asked them if
we could do some Q&A so we'll do some
questions and then we're gonna do a
fireside chat so first of all I'm just
very flattered to be here thank you for
having me for the people in this room
that don't know who I am I was born in
the Soviet Union came to America when I
was a three-year-old child very tough
upbringing we were very poor when we
first came to America I lived in a one
studio apartment with seven of my family
members my parent my dad worked all the
time and so it was a very rough
upbringing not a lot of entitlement
didn't have a lot of stuff my natural
state was to be an entrepreneur even at
six seven years old I was already
shoveling snow you know washing people's
cars selling juice and lemonade in candy
it was always to do a hustle somewhere
along that time in New Jersey sports
cards became a very big thing in America
baseball cards American football cards
and I started collecting them and by the
time I was 13 14 years old I was making
one two three thousand dollars a weekend
as a 13 year old child which you can
imagine feels like you're a millionaire
eventually my dad worked very hard and
saved all his money and he bought a
small liquor store in New Jersey I was
forced to work in that store and that is
really where I started my real career I
fell in love with the idea of knowing
that a lot of people in America
collected wine and that was what kind of
connected me to my family business the
part of the story that gets interesting
for this room is what happens next
knowing that there's a lot of
entrepreneurs in here knowing there's a
lot of small businesses a lot
small business agencies what really
enables me the great flattering nature
to be in this room is the fact that my
entire career was based on how do I
build something with not a lot of money
you know we live in a world right now
where a lot of people and how many by
show of hands how many people in this
room are entrepreneurs and have their
own business raise your hands raise it
high thank you so if we can keep the
lights on that'd be amazing I love that
um so for me what's interesting about
all those hands that are up is I'm older
you know I'm 43 about to be 44 next week
and when I grew up the idea of raising
capital was extremely foreign one of the
most interesting things being an
American businessman when I travel
nationally internationally in other
places the world is everybody is so
caught up with raising money for their
startup this has become an entire
generation of hands in the air that
think about raising capital and
appeasing venture capitalists and
investors not actually building a
business and not having the focus there
and to me this is very interesting
because it's led to a lot of very
different behavior for me everything was
always about how do you make money and
that's what you invest back into your
business not how do you raise capital
when I started my current company
vaynermedia
which is an advertising agency I started
it in the conference room of another
company because I had no money and I
wasn't gonna raise money for the
business I was just gonna find my first
client use those dollars and just keep
reinvesting it took longer but longer
was it strength I think one of the most
important words for me to communicate in
this talk today by far is patience I
promise you no matter what you're doing
in this room and especially as I look
around this room
first of all everyone's uncomfortably
attractive and number two and number two
but more importantly this is quite a
young audience and I think the reality
is
the thing that I spend most of my time
on is trying to get people to understand
that patience is a very important
variable of success and more importantly
that I believe the far majority of
people in this room do not have a great
relationship with time I am fascinated
by people in this room who are stressed
at the ages of 18 and 22 and 25 and 29
like they're running out of time how
many people by show of hands are under
30 years old so for me as you can
imagine when I see all those hands go up
you can put your hand down yeah you're
good okay good when I see all those
hands go up and I know in my mind with
the way that modern medicine and
technology is going that the far
majority of this room is gonna live for
another 80 years it really gets me
excited / concerned when people want
their business to be huge
next year the quicker you want it the
more vulnerable you are the quicker you
want it the more vulnerable you are and
what has been very fascinating for me is
even though on YouTube and Instagram and
maybe some of the places you guys see me
maybe my energy is high
maybe my style of communication is fast
but my business actions are extremely
slow and so what business actions that
lead to slowness lead to is a couple
things one the far majority of my career
I had no money so I had to always look
for places where you could get a lot
more for less what I look for in the
digital world this world is organic
reach when I think about organic reach
and when I think about organic attention
as my slide says up here I day trade
attention for me every day I look at the
data both in the analytics
and in the culture conversations to try
to figure out where should I mark it I
promise you one thing my friends no
matter what you do in this audience no
matter what your ambition is the one
thing that combines all of us whether
we're starting tomorrow whether we're an
employee whether we have a huge company
or haven't even started and are starting
next year the one requirement for all of
us is to have somebody's attention
before you can sell anything you need
somebody's attention then what you say
in the written word in audio or in video
becomes the variable if you are
successful the reason I follow attention
is if there was nobody in here right now
and I was giving this talk I would have
no potential to achieve what I want at
the same token with all of you in this
room what I talk about for the next hour
and a half is the variable of my success
there are many of you here that don't
know who I am you'll leave with opinion
there's many people who do know who I am
and you're either gonna like me more or
like me less completely predicated on
the content that I put out I spend my
life in a very basic mind frame and if
you look at the politics of your country
my country if you look at the businesses
it's all one very simple game do you
understand where the people are and
they're consuming and do you understand
how to do the written words the audio or
the video to put in those platforms this
is how it's always been
television radio print outdoor
billboards it's always been the same
game where is the attention the eyes and
the ears and what is our capability to
put content in it now here's where it
gets different this thing is [ __ ]
crazy
this thing is unbelievably
underestimated we in this room take this
for granted the power of a phone in
today's world is remarkable the fact
that every one of us are sitting here
with the internet in our hands right now
is actually remarkable for
he liked me at 43 years old when I was
28 I could not leave the office or my
home and have the internet in my hand
when I was thirty you have to understand
how big of a deal that is you have to
understand how quickly this is all
happening whether it's whatsapp or
YouTube or Instagram or tic toc or
Twitter the fact that these platforms
sit on top of this device and they're
accessible right now the fact that there
are tons of people right now with a
phone recording this talk and then have
the ability to post it my friends from
Brazil to New York to London to Shanghai
the human race has not quantified how
substantial this shift of the internet
has become and I tell you this and I
start my talk here today with this
because here's the real honest truth
about how the game of life and
definitely business is played the
quickest way to be happy in life let
alone business is to be 100% accountable
the quickest way to be unhappy is to
blame if you really understood the last
five to seven minutes of what I just
said the fact that how many people here
have a cellphone
raise your hands good every single
person here fundamentally is not allowed
to have an excuse because of the power
of what's in your hand
of course there's family dynamics of
course there's tragedies of course
there's government involvement of course
there's a million reasons but the
reality is we have never lived through a
time where people at scale had so much
opportunity when I do the homework on
the Brazilian market and I see the cost
for a YouTube ad or an Instagram ad and
I see how low it is when I see how much
still unbelievable untapped potential on
LinkedIn and
tick tock and other platforms are for
organic reach where you have to spend no
money none and you can get awareness the
fact that podcasting is exploding in
this country and the cost to start a
podcast is to just record it on your
phone and upload it
the thing that I've become unbelievably
fascinated by is I know in this room the
single reason whatever is not happening
for you is your ability to say no before
you've tried that to me is unbelievable
what's unbelievable to me is it's as
simple as this if you are capable of
writing words recording videos on your
phone or recording your thoughts in
audio on your phone your business can
grow your idea can be flourished your
personal brand is an influencer your
advertising shop trying to get more
customers whatever you you want to be
the governor you want to be a YouTube
celebrity the reality is the cost is
zero the mindset is the tricky part
90% of this audience does not post as
often as they should on these platforms
because they worry about the judgement
of their family or strangers this is a
very very very fascinating dilemma in
our society there are people who are not
posting I mean look how many people here
to follow my content give me a sense
raise your hands thank you so for the
hands that went up you know what you're
gonna get from me today I'm very
consistent I'm you can I'm sure you're
in your head knowing every word I'm
about to say as I start a sentence I'm
incapable of talking about something I
don't believe in you know the nuances
are different obviously Twitter doesn't
play in this country the same way it
does in the US right tick tocks moving
quicker in Asia and the US than it is in
other places
LinkedIn's acting a little bit different
here what's up has higher growth here
than it does in the US there's nuance
differences but
my friends this is not about America or
Brazil this is about human beings in
America in Brazil in China people worry
about their parents opinion in America
in Brazil in China people care about
strangers
making fun of them in the comments in
America in Brazil in China the
opportunity to build your business or
your personal brand has never been
easier easier people see more people
doing it and they think they're too late
the real answer is 99% of the people in
here do not have the patience and
stomach to actually achieve it they want
it so fast my friends I did Wine Library
TV on YouTube in 2006
excuse me 2007 to 2010 for 35 minutes a
day five days a week I would stay up and
work on Twitter for four or five hours
looking for people who were talking
about wine and for three years every day
very little happened for me very little
people now start an Instagram account
post for six weeks and give up because
they're not getting enough followers we
have become remarkably impatient we've
become remarkably entitled and so the
reality is is the following tactically
tactically how many people here are b2b
companies they have an agency servicing
clients or some of the major you're in a
b2b business raise your hands for
everybody that raised her hand you must
you must do one of two things
consistently starting tomorrow
number one start a podcast in your
industry you must start a podcast go on
LinkedIn go into your inbox and email 25
50 people and ask them to be guests on
your show and number two you must attack
LinkedIn more I think people very much
underestimate how much is happening
there in this market I did the homework
it's there
it you know
don't see it because not that many
people are doing it which is the reason
it's most interesting it's you know it's
so funny when I speak at these events
people always fall into two groups
number one they don't want to do it
because it's new and they want to see
other people do it before they do it
or number two other people are doing it
so they think they're too late so they
don't want to do it people are split up
in two places of not doing we live in a
world a world where everybody has a
reason for no I can't do it because of
this I don't have the money I don't have
the team my industry doesn't want to do
it I can't I can't I can't
the fundamental difference in the game
today is the people that say yes blindly
versus the people that say no blindly
the only unique leverage you have in
this room is you yourself there's so
much information now you're not coming
up with any new idea there's nothing I
say that is a new idea people have been
around too long I'm not the first person
to talk about kindness or gratitude or
empathy or hard work or context I'm
really not I'm just doing it my way in
the way my perspective my words on my
platform and for me this is the real
conversation today to me is today gonna
be the conference is today gonna be the
time that you finally understand that it
is time to put it out it is time to tell
your story at scale contextually across
all platforms recognizing that a lot of
people did not raise their hand and this
may be the first time that a lot of you
are seeing me I'm just gonna take one
more step back I believe that what the
internet is doing is eliminating the
middle it's eliminating the middle the
distribution when you look at uber or
Amazon or if you look at Netflix what
it's really doing is separating out the
middle and it's leaving it to one of two
places the product the story the service
and your ability to tell
that story I believe this is very
important because this is not even for
the youngsters in this room this is not
the world we necessarily grew up with a
world where the entire middle of
distribution has been commoditized
because the Internet has become the
middle and the focus on not just the
quality of the product but more
importantly the deep focus on the
ability to communicate has never become
greater the ability to be a communicator
in 2020 has now become
disproportionately more powerful than
even the quality of your product and
that may be confusing and it's a very
interesting debate but the reality is a
product is a subjective product one more
time b2b who does services raise it high
I just want to get cents higher all of
you that just raise your hands you know
what I know sometimes you think the
products great but your client thinks
it's [ __ ] other times you kind of know
that the product is shitty but the
client thinks it's great the work is
subjective based on the queen or the
King on the other side who gets to
decide your ability to be a phenomenal
communicator how many people see it
where and how is less subjective the
content in it is subjective but the
results are they are through the leads
through the results that come through it
I believe today that if you're in the
business world that the ability to be a
communicator a Content producer at the
height of the scale for your product has
become more important than any other
variable I would rather be great at
YouTube and podcasting and LinkedIn and
Instagram
than be great at balancing my checkbook
that I can hire an accountant for this
skill is emerging
accelerating at scale so here's how this
game breaks down for me one I think
everybody here has to take a step back
and figure out what kind of communicator
are they individually even if you sit
here today and do not believe it is your
job within the organization to
communicate eventually especially at the
age level that everybody here is
eventually this skill set will become
important to you whether it's now later
in your career within your family
dynamics and definitely over the next 20
30 40 years as communication rises in
importance not declines thus my great
ask my great ambition to fly down here
are three flights to get here and flying
right back home the reason for me to be
here is very focused on the notion of
can I get five people there's a lot of
people here can I get five people in
here to start tomorrow or Monday if you
want to take the weekend off to start
making content the world is very simple
the world is breaking into a very simple
game ideas and making do you have ideas
can you make them but it requires an
incredible sense of self-awareness I'm
very passionate for many people in this
room who are introverted and who would
be scared
to give this speech or who feel
uncomfortable in front of a camera to
understand that if you were a remarkable
writer there's an incredible world for
you for those who are scared to be in
front of the camera because they're
scared of how they look or they're just
uncomfortable that recording your ideas
or what you're about in audio is an
incredible time to be alive and there's
an incredible world to you it's a matter
of fact even more interesting to me if
you're somebody that likes to doodle to
draw some of the most exciting things
that I'm seeing in my content is when
we're doing
cartoons on LinkedIn and Instagram that
might be the way that you communicate
when you figure out how you communicate
written word audio video the next part
is definitely the most challenging if
you ask me why over the last ten years I
have been given the great fortune to be
here it's very simple I spend almost all
of my time and all of my content trying
to bring value with no expectation in
return if you look at the content that
most people and companies and
organizations put out if you look at it
carefully and you dissect it it is
wildly selfish
it is either a commercial in itself or
its main objective is to get you to fill
out your email your phone number your
information so that I can sell to you
instead of bring you value to build a
brand I wrote a book several years ago
called Jab Jab Jab right hook and the
reason I wrote it was because I was
watching people on social media really
struggle with the idea of bringing value
and I wanted to give them a scenario of
understanding that if you're trying to
sell and throw a right hook all the time
eventually the other person knows how to
duck everybody how many people here have
done email marketing in their life raise
your hands
great so for everybody who just raised
their hands I was doing email marketing
in 1997-1998
and I had 90% open rates on my email
today if you're in the 30s you're a hero
means you have a tremendous list and
you're doing a great job the reason
those lists have gone from 90 to 30 is
because I'm sure everybody here knows
where I'm going we've ruined email
because we're spamming and selling on it
at all times that's what happens to
every platform that's exactly what we're
doing on social media now the reason
social media is subtly declining
the reason the algorithms always have to
change is people do not have the
disciplined to not self promote people
do not have the disciplined to not try
to sell on every post the other problem
is when people try to make pretend
they're giving value in disguise
underneath they're actually trying to
sell my friends what's scary about the
way I go about business and what I
believe I see what the businesses that
are most winning in the world is it
super basic just nobody wants to do it
it almost be like if I was standing up
here talking about health and wellness
my friends if you want to get into
better shape here's how you do it
stop eating [ __ ] and workout every day
thank you very much see you later Brazil
that would be the whole talk that is no
different than how I see business today
obviously you have to have a product and
service but the reality is very simply
the formula is as basic as it is in
Fitness if you are not producing content
and when I say content just to put this
into context for everybody next week is
my birthday I've had my team work for
the last month we've made a deck a
couple hundred pages deck we're gonna
give it away for free it shows you how
to make 60 something pieces of content
in a day the reality is the requirement
of how much content that I'm looking for
you to produce to achieve what you think
about numbers that look like 30 40 50 60
pieces of content a day most of the
businesses and people in here are
putting out one piece of content a day
on a good day maybe three a week we if
you're a personal brand you're killing
it and posting four things a day there
is nobody that is achieving the volume
if you want to write down one word and
stick it in your mirror from this whole
talk the word is volume this is a volume
warfare
when people hear volume they hear
quantity when they hear quantity they
don't think that you can make quality
they think it's a friction between
quantity and quality I believe that the
world has grossly overvalued production
quality and made that quality not the
story or the context of the message and
so as we have spent the last 30 to 50
years putting production value on a
pedestal as quality we have put
ourselves in a position to not value
context and the actual story and in that
is the rub and the opportunity the sheer
size of this country the sheer amount of
spend even in the separation of wealth
the uncanny amount of attention on
YouTube and Instagram in this country
leads this to be one of the most
interesting places in the world to be a
marketer to be a marketer to be an
influencer to be a startup however when
I spent because I gave a speech in San
Paulo a couple of weeks ago so about
three months ago I started really doing
homework on what's the sentiment what
are people saying in the comments what's
the vibe
what's remarkable in such a progressive
and incredible country is how much
similarities there are believe it or not
with the US which is with all that in
place there is still so much cynicism
and pessimism to actually achieve it
that is not a government issue with your
new President or ours that is not a
problem that you don't have Silicon
Valley that is a problem that people
would rather complain than put in the
[ __ ] work that is a human problem
that is a global human problem if this
was 1957 and it was my grandfather and
all of your grandparents I would have
some empathy because it took real money
to actually do what I'm saying
but in 2019 with this I struggle to
deploy empathy for you not doing which
is what led me to not making this a game
about your wallet many people think
business is a game of this this is not a
game of this this is right now is a game
of this this has come down to the simple
deep warfare in one's head what what is
stopping people from actually making
content and I believe that it comes down
to one simple word judgment I believe
the judgment is crippling our society I
am fascinated and grateful grateful like
you would not imagine for my mother
building self-esteem in me without
creating entitlement my self-esteem
allows when I leave here in a couple of
hours and I read the comments and I
control copy it and translate it from
Portuguese to English where one of you
say that I'm an [ __ ] I'm okay I want
to give the next talk I want to make the
next piece of content my ability to deal
with losing pushback negativity no is my
strength my entire model of content
production my entire thesis for this
talk only has one major flaw and that
people are insecure I spend my life
putting out content 50 70 80 pieces a
day with the great hope to eliminate
that insecurity to challenge you and ask
you what judgment why why are you
willing to live a life that ultimately
ends with regret and resentment because
everybody who's 90 had a hundred years
old
talks about the things they wish they
did
not the things they did and so for me
Brazil very simply I'm trying to
challenge this room to understand the
simplicity of the framework and the mass
of difficulty in the head and really
lead to a couple tactics for example
tactic number one one of the biggest
things that I have seen work in people
starting the process to produce content
is to make a single video and tell the
world their secret that they've been
holding on to if you really think about
what's stopping people it's the darkness
and shadows inside of them by putting it
out and taking control of your secret
your dyslexia your terrible issue as a
child your relationship with X your
drinking problem whatever it might be by
you taking control of it by putting it
out no longer does anybody else have
leverage to expose it it is a freedom
play and I highly enlist it if you
really want to know forget about the
five people that post tomorrow if I can
get one person one person in here to
leave this conference tonight and make a
video and tell the world the truth that
they've been holding on to this will be
mission [ __ ] accomplished thank you
Dad
I want to go into questions in about
five or ten minutes so let's make let me
see where the mics are but I'm gonna
line them up here and we'll figure that
out but before I do I want to spend a
few more minutes on audio for a lot of
people here they missed YouTube they
missed Instagram I believe there's two
places where you have a chance over the
next couple of years to not miss it
number one you have to watch tick tock
very carefully if tick tock takes off
seriously in this market there will be
an enormous amount of opportunity
because the global penetration in Asia
the US Europe is exploding what's so
amazing to live in a country of this
size and this much opportunity and you
guys know this is you can see these
platforms exploding somewhere else and
you can get a head start and play it
here outside of Orkut which became the
player here every other platform
eventually makes its way here and became
the dominant player please please do not
underestimate what is happening on tick
tock globally and where the potential
sits in this market you should
absolutely if you're at this conference
if you're smart enough to be at this
conference you should be smart enough to
go home and execute around the thesis
around the opportunities around the
knowledge one is tick tock number two is
voice we are becoming much more of an
audio consumption world by show of hands
how many people here now listen to a
podcast raise your hands raise it high
I want everybody look around look at
this put it down for a second those same
people how many of you were listening to
a podcast five years ago raise your hand
look around look at that growth look at
that growth how many people here now
when they watch youtube videos sometimes
just put the phone down
and listen to it and don't even watch
the video raise your hands look at this
look at this d-roc spends all this time
making it look pretty
[ __ ] just listen to it audio is
becoming the growing usage because we're
busy and we want to do two things at
once
three things at once four things at once
one of the biggest opportunities in this
room is understanding how big audio is
and producing audio content everybody
wants to be a marketer the most people
in this room are salespeople it's why
they like Google Google is easy its
intent somebody types something in you
know they want it so you buy the ads and
you convert that's sales I'm here to
talk about branding and marketing you
know the way real things are built the
way the biggest companies in the world
are built the biggest personalities
celebrities brands they're built through
branding and marketing not sales audio
is no question the fastest growing
opportunity to build brand that most
people are not doing please be the
person in this room that goes back and
actually starts a podcast please be the
person here who actually starts
recording their thoughts and just
posting the video I mean you could
literally take your phone hit memo
record put the phone down it's just a
black screen and you can post a black
screen with your words you can most of
you won't because you don't think that's
quality this subjective point of view
around quality is stopping the world for
making we must flip that on its head
please be the person in this room that
leaves here and starts making thank you
thank you
thank you thank you I left a lot of time
for Q&A because I really you know the
theory is very simple the details and
the questions matter so who's got the
mics you got the mics so you got to run
around who's got a question raise your
hands yep okay yeah hi hi I love you
actually my family whole family loves
you
thank you I just came from Canada so I
am Amin immigrants in Canada I my son
listen to your podcast everyday he's
nine years old my daughter
sorry about the cursing yeah 11 years
old so I asked him what do you want to
say to Garrity he said say to him that I
love him then he's awesome and I'm sorry
and you are so fun I really love you
thank you thank you for that and I'm
shaking because as you know I'm leaving
Canada for 13 years now and I suffer a
lot
it was terrible even for my children
that was born there and if I from there
just to eat Brazilian food at the school
was very scary and my my daughter was
bullying because of that so my question
is why is a mom do for my kids
sure so you're welcome thank you for
being so dope yes you can have a photo
so I think business and parenting have a
lot of similarities so when I hear those
kind of stories and I'm sure how many
people here are parents raise your hands
so for all the hands that just went up
you know how challenging it is like you
can have common sense everywhere else
but when it's your kids it's hard to
maintain it but I believe that
self-esteem is the ultimate cure to
everything and I think most parents go
on defense when their kids are hurting
instead of offense so when their kids
are bullied they want to go fight the
school
they want to go fight the parent of the
kid its defense for me as somebody who
was bullied because I was you know I was
a Soviet immigrant in America and my
childhood when the Soviet Union was the
enemy there was plenty of [ __ ] I mean if
he can zoom in I've got goose bumps it
was a very challenging time but what my
mom did was she went insular it was
offense it was me and her in my own head
hearing nothing else by the time I was
in high school I couldn't hear anybody
else it didn't matter
by the way both pro and con so for me I
think the thing you can do is be into
their head about them not about the
people in Montreal or Toronto or Canada
it's not about them it's about yourself
inside your own head your own self-worth
and and you have to pound it a lot of
parents you're like oh CZ to say but
when their kids are making you're right
it's but it's no different than working
out and eating healthy it's no different
than make content and put it on all the
platforms the answer is simple pound
into your kids had their own self-worth
not the opinions of others there'll be a
happy person or whole life the problem
is most parents aren't acting that way
so it's hard for them to give advice
that they don't even feel themselves but
that is the answer you're welcome
questions yeah yeah thank you hey how
are you find you very good been
following you for many years so I am so
happy to be with you thank you I'm kind
of nervous don't worry okay
so I came all the way from dreamy little
town in San Juan in Argentina called San
Juan so I mean I've been for a couple
month of maybe years trying to figure
out if I have to leave my small town or
just stay run derby patience I wait for
my business to be like big what kind of
system of a digital agency so my
question is like would you imagine
yourself as a businessman as the sizes
right now staying in New Jersey for
example or a small town I understand so
the question for you and everybody here
is what's big right because because this
is where people get caught it's so
simple being in a small town in
Argentina thinking you have to go to San
Paulo or you have to go to Buenos Aires
or you have to go to New York City it's
easy it's easy you're like that's a much
bigger place to go the question is it
comes down to what makes you happy for
me what makes me happy is to play the
game not the money not how big or small
I just want to play I've always wanted
to play I've watched so many people have
a 1 million dollar business in a small
town in America or in the world move to
a bigger place do five million and be
very unhappy they were very happy at 1
million in their small town they went to
a bigger town they do 10 million and
they're very unhappy my friend
Brazil it is time that we in the world
start making happiness what we go after
not more money thank you
we have to we have to right for me when
I hear bigger I want you to have a
bigger [ __ ] smile on your pretty face
not make 280,000 more in [ __ ] net
revenue you understand you have to
decide that for yourself I don't know
you you have to decide that for yourself
how are you for almost three years and I
just want to say thank you for all of
your content you really change it by
life and with me in the world to have a
picture with you can i yes you can thank
you right now right now thank you
keep the mic back how are you
[Applause]
all right get out of here Oh
let's go who's next hi first of all I'm
a huge fan thank you I've taught me a
lot about perspective and ready to
happiness I'm so nervous
don't be so mean my sister we're
starting a b2b company and we are trying
to sell training and consulting for HR
teams and litter teams okay I know we
are not putting as many content as you
should out there why why do you think
talk to be real we're here why well she
lives in another town okay it's a little
difficult for us well you don't both
have to be in the content yeah yeah and
but she needs a lot of help you know for
me because I know how to do things and
how to how to film videos and I'm I'm
teaching her okay and she's a little she
doesn't have a lot of confidence she's
she's really good she knows her craft
yeah so what about writing or what about
audio I feel like so many people that
don't have confidence are very scared of
the camera but can do much much better
writing or recording audio yeah this is
why I spent so much time on it in my
talk I don't want people to be like me
not listen not everybody is ridiculously
handsome and charismatic you know what I
mean though I don't want people to be
like me I want people to be like me
where they found their voice in their
medium but for a lot of you in this room
that's writing you know if you're more
introverted or insecure a lot of writers
are come from that framework or I really
like audio so keep that in mind but keep
going
trying to reach companies in her region
but I'm just guessing one what else can
we do besides content that I know you
should be doing to get our first clients
just do it for free yeah the biggest
mistakes small companies make is they
don't work for free
and then you know now that I said this
on the internet so many people are gonna
leave comments and say that I'm an idiot
and they hate me and nobody should work
for free and blah blah blah
that's fine but those are set by people
that have never started a company with
no customers that's right
and so I would I mean I did it and I had
already built a big business but I went
into a new world where people thought
what I did for the liquor store was not
gonna work so I worked for free I still
do it if I think it's the right strategy
so I think the biggest thing you should
do is work for free cuz it gives you the
referral base and and by the way when
nobody's hiring you that means your work
is worth free can I have a selfie okay
Peralta who's next done there Gary how
are you doing
go ahead I can listen okay Gary and Miss
bozo each team is gonna go through him a
few demos converse a don't graduate
don't remain thank you a preguntamos
rich for saying yes again shift obvious
who the hell dad went to the key
khonanesta no contest no massage windows
no kimonos no kimonos in th conversation
my [ __ ] life Ellis preseason Jesus
will scare you soon
chuckling prayer service used to the
moon the damn so like education what was
the price would de asís [ __ ] don't try
to convince anybody the number one
mistake when you're selling something
new that most people don't understand is
people
spend too much time trying to convince
them instead of finding the person that
already understands people make it a
noble mission instead of a business my
friend I've been right and early for the
last 20 years of my life I have spent
almost no time trying to convince
anybody I sometimes have a one-hour
meeting with a company fly from New York
to Chicago walk in sit down start the
presentation and end it after 10 minutes
because I already know it's over every
minute that you spend trying to convince
somebody who's already know is a minute
that you're not spending trying to find
somebody that will say yes of course
because you're not when you're selling
something new they can't see it or they
don't have reports in their company to
justify it got it so if they don't have
the report to justify your work they're
scared they might agree with you but the
machine that they work in won't allow
them to say yes so you just move on
you're welcome
sign it okay next hello how are you well
you're awesome
my name is Luka and I watch our content
since I'm 19 now I'm Finn - so thank you
for being part of that thank you
I want to ask you something that I
believe is really important you are the
first guy to talk about making homes and
making really quality content but I'm
afraid that the internet still is a
place with very anxiety
I mean Eastern growing cause a lot of
anxiety also Graham doesn't cause
anything people are anxious yes this is
important
Instagram there is no Instagram there's
a platform we post pictures and humans
decide to see somebody having a nice
time and they decide to be upset it's
important though keep going
yeah my my question is how can we we all
hear this event can help these platforms
all platforms be mindful be Betterton by
putting out by putting out real [ __ ] if
everybody here didn't only put out
photos when they're most dressed up
going to the most fancy place and
showing everybody how [ __ ] amazing
their life is the world would be in a
better place thank you not super
complicated
d-roc and i are gonna end this talk I'm
about to do in five minutes the fireside
chat we're gonna do a book signing we're
gonna run to the airport we're gonna
take a private plane because I have to
get the sim Paulo because I want to get
home for family early tomorrow morning
there will be no picture of me at a
private plane I'm not gonna show that
I'm fancy that's not what I want to talk
about I want to talk about gratitude and
kindness and empathy we're in control
there's no [ __ ] Instagram monster
there's no YouTube monster were the
monster
[Applause]
all right I go okay yeah so when
producing content language matters yes
we're in the country that doesn't speak
English yes so said that how can we
break the language but here to go global
well you know you're not gonna get
Portuguese to go global
yes I mean what's the better best way to
go in English and Portuguese bilingual
do it both and I mean but just in one
one profile but two profiles or you can
do two profiles I'm a big fan of
sometimes doing video that is both in
Portuguese and English I also want to
remind you that this is a humongous
[ __ ] country and winning here is just
fine - yeah you know I mean if you want
to win globally and you're so desperate
to then you're more than welcome to make
English yeah because Curren matters I
mean it's a big opportunity I understand
that I think it all comes back to the
gentleman from Argentina you have to
decide what's right for you if you want
global if you're chasing more dollars
then make English content okay so but
but it's very important I say this I I
think this is every country outside of
China and the US has an inferior complex
because there's more money elsewhere
this is a huge [ __ ] country like like
huge so close in Brazil if that's what
you want to but if you know I can
promise you just focusing in Brazil but
just Portuguese content can make you
plenty of money and happiness if you
personally want to be on a bigger stage
English is something you have to
consider okay thank you you're welcome
hey Gary good evening good evening
first of all you keep you yet CBL Oh
blue yeah Tory well that means I love
you in Russian yeah so I'll just give
you a very quick contest because I want
to respect everyone's time
when I was four years old my mom stabbed
me for eating all the cucumbers we had
fur DAP you my hand yes okay when I was
six she smashed my face against the wall
until they bled from my nose and teeth
just was just because I was late one
hour then she threw me at the graveyard
when it was late at night and honestly
all my life was fear and sadness and
sorrow and so when I was 20 years old I
said either I kill myself or I go
so I decided I go and I left my mom and
a few years later I became an
entrepreneur and I'm not the most
successful one but I've done pretty good
for myself
quite happy okay and
[Applause]
but it's a story that resonates with me
it's something I share very infrequently
but my grandmother who passed away this
year and maybe that's why I'm a little
bit more comfortable sharing it
she was very difficult - my father - in
the Soviet Russia so I have a lot of
empathy for that story and I also know
and I know you know this because I see
you made some doll with my face on it
so obviously you're following I believe
that adversity in youth is a very
powerful advantage if you're able to get
out of it if you're lucky enough to be
born with natural mindset or consume
something that helps you get out of it
100% so I came along away but I did
become an entrepreneur out of vengeance
and wanted to get even with my mom my
dad my everyone and I knew how unhealthy
it was and then came along this American
Russian who speaks way too much and
krisis even more and somehow I don't
know how I really don't know but but you
changed me today I work for happiness I
work for helping other people rather
than closing the most deals and I came
here to practice what you preach which
is Jab Jab Jab right hook so let's start
with the jabs please then we go to the
right hook please thank you first of all
Gary Vaynerchuk I'd like you to meet
Gary Vaynerchuk also I'd like you to
meet Sasha Vaynerchuk very nice and to
make it devastating tomorrow Vaynerchuk
very nice my two favorite people on
earth yes thank you now I know you're
private man so I'll make it in Russian
if you want I'll do it for free I'll do
what she did um
Ivana 100 cent but now we just have Leo
you send me an email to Gary at
vaynermedia
and we'll get hooked up thank you you're
welcome so thank you now here's my right
hook and regardless of what you say yes
or no what I said earlier I'll deliver
I'm desperately need 20 minutes FaceTime
with you whenever you want wherever you
want please okay two things one Jab Jab
Jab right hook when you give give give
and then ask it's unbelievably important
to me that people understand that when
you give with something behind it it's
not giving so the execution of that for
the 20 minutes is not how I see the
world however I just want to make sure
everybody understands that however even
with that said and usually it's not my
favorite move when somebody gives me
something I didn't ask for and then
needs something for me which is the most
valuable thing from me my actual time
even though I don't love that
I just love you thank you and I will
give you the 20 minutes thank you thank
you email me will get connect it's Gary
really yeah I'm gonna get one more in
and then I'm gonna call up the CEO we're
gonna have this far section yes you got
it I love you I love you back okay thank
you
we only can a bro inside for 17 years we
are spreading contact all the time and
[Music]
the big companies coming from united
states as you know we can't have
sponsored ads on facebook I'm aware so
asking use any iDevice influencers
because that's the most scalable thing
so giving the dollars to the influencer
they post and sometimes it stays up
sometimes it doesn't but my number one
thing and you know I do a lot in the US
with cannabis with my greens free
company you have to start a podcast you
have to control the media podcast and
even text messaging starting to ask
people for their cell phone numbers and
putting
content directly to them and we work
very hard and chat but also 100% but
even the chat bada fits in within what
if it's in whatsapp you're gonna be
vulnerable you want to go direct phone
numbers and you want to start a podcast
company because there's no platform in
the middle that's in control of you all
right thank you thank you all right
let's do the fireside chat thank you
everyone
yuria this is very good [ __ ] so you're
gonna do a couple more it's all about
them so I can get my interview I'm happy
to do it
yeah all right be right here who's got
the mics no problem I just don't know
where the mics are who's got the mics go
ahead yep she's got it yep that's fine
and then let's and then let's go into
the way [ __ ] back I want to get some
of those peeps hello hello Gary my name
is Tiago me and my girlfriend we drove
380 miles just to see you and meet you
thank you I just want to thank you for
everything you did I brought Prussians
with me thank you this book changed my
life I'm I work as a doctor but I
happened to be passionate about
technology so I started my youtube
channel following her advice my oh my
last year one when a half year ago and
it's starting to to grow exponentially
you talked you told me about voice I
made Alexa contacted blew up my
girlfriend was unhappy at her job and I
said read this book and then she kept on
complaining about her job and I said
quit you're not Gary says quit and she
quit her job and now she started her own
slow fashion business she's happy as she
ever been and we want to thank you so
much and ask if you could sign my book
and take a picture reverse plea 100%
thank you 100%
who's got the mic right over there go
ahead get her attention she's got the
mic good
no just I think it's really important to
talk about business that is really neat
in Brazil there is schools school
teaching of course and I am the first
people put the first person here that
actually didn't know you before our this
summit no problem a lot of people didn't
yeah I wasn't a big fan of you I am now
your person I just wanted your opinion
on how you think that teaching is gonna
grow in these platforms like YouTube
Internet in general do you think that
actually we're gonna have a boom let's
say teaching is gonna explode on the
internet do you think that's I think it
in the future
I do and I think it's already happened
you know I think you and I have grown up
in the last hundred years of modern
teaching where education is being done
through schools and leveling up until
final University and then go into the
world I believe that education is
already happening if you just think
about what that doctor you know was just
saying literally the question before he
watched my content in education form it
educated him to the possibilities and
then he went and executed it I think to
your point and I'll you can you can add
we can talk back and forth I think
people that are educators in the current
system are gonna have to be very
thoughtful that are they passionate
about being a teacher in the current
system or they passionate about
educating in the macro yeah that's
actually the the point I was trying to
get like yeah I know there's a lot of
people already teaching other people or
on the internet my the thing I was
thinking is that my idea of future the
thing I want to do in my future is
teaching people online specific
languages but you can do that now yeah I
know but do you my question is do you
think teaching is gonna go entirely to
the Internet do you think I think
society is gonna go predominantly to the
Internet will still live in real life
but there's a very significant chance in
30 40 50 years that all of us are living
in virtual reality and are spending a
lot of time in that world
no different than the eleven hours we
spend inside our of our phone now yes I
do
like ready player one the movie yeah
listen I think people in this room
including me are very naive of where
technology is going already we can see
blockchain VR AR there's so many more
inventions that will be invented before
we die technology always moves
technology always moves so yes I think
so
thank you okay who's got the next
question III need mics we got you okay -
Joe hey Gary how are you
Karasu topic I remember Dylan Vinci has
superior powers against preemie remains
at America been interesting please
Chrissa bastard why James was resolved
in Jogja to - ah Roger akin to the
Internet multiple controversy Eurasian
photos which the enemy avidity newest
compromise my stable video tell Kimmy -
annoyed impacted you fight wanna speak
on toe 10 concealed in flesh palabras
was a dispersive I'm oh hey this is
finished you click Osaka matazo breeze
yeah I mean brother I my biggest hope
for everybody is to not have regret
besides health health which you need I
want people to have
happiness and as much happiness and as
little regret and you know you're such a
young man we have so much time we have
so much time I just wish that people had
a better relationship with time there's
so much more time and so I'm glad that
that hit you because it's very real
everything I do everything is knowing
that it's almost impossible to be a
human being
400 trillion to one that is the math the
odds of being a the odds of being
somebody in here right now is 400
trillion to one it's impossible to be a
human being and yet everybody here is
one and I don't want you to waste it
why to al-qaeda man thank you why thank
you yep we can do the last one yeah hi
hi all right
earlier you gave us advice for producing
content and I asked today for Roberto
prado from Microsoft what Reed tools do
you have every day that changes your
life and I want what what brother what
what rituals retails is yes that you do
every day and it changes your life every
day yeah every day at some point I
imagine my children or my parents or my
siblings somebody in my family dying
every day and that makes me happy and I
know that that might be confusing but
every day I practice reminding myself
what is actually important to me and if
today I went to Brazil and gave a great
speech and many people found out about
me and when I got back to my phone in an
hour one of my clients gave us five
million dollars more for vaynermedia
and one of my videos went viral on
Instagram and got 5 million views and
maybe even this Sunday the Jets win a
[ __ ] football game right
if all that happened if all that
happened if god forbid one of the 20
people that I love the most got sick or
died I would not give a [ __ ]
my only ritual every day is to make
perfect pretend somebody that I loved
died which makes the rest of my day
very easy amazing thank you
[Applause]
do them in a very tough spot here I'm
cutting this great conversation short
yeah I'm also between you in your flight
and between them and party with free
beer so free beer is fun so
unfortunately guys this conference is
coming to an end did you like it yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so my my only mission here is try to
wrap up this conversation with some of
the important things that we discuss
here I think we all agree that we had
amazing three days the last three days
those are my questions to to you I'm a
big fan since the Wine Library days I
actually met you I'd ever probably don't
remember that matter you had web 2.0 X 4
2009 so that was a long time ago
Portugal yeah in some San Francisco yeah
so my first question is you want to buy
the Jets yes most people here probably
don't know why so what I want to know is
what's the power of stating out publicly
a goal like that
and in please explain why you went about
it yeah when I was a 5 years old 6 years
old I moved to New Jersey I wasn't
speaking English I had a very tough time
and when I first came to America I went
outside and some boys were throwing an
American football
I went over started playing and they
said to me what team do you like I
didn't know they said you're a New York
Jets fan I said ok that was 1982 every
single Sunday since that day I have
watched every single play of the Jets
during that summer for a year later all
my friends had Jets jerseys we were poor
so I asked my mom to buy a jet jersey
and she said no but at night she knitted
and made me a Jets sweater that is my
prized possession I have it in a safety
deposit box when I buy the football team
I'm gonna hang it as soon as you walk in
for me the Jets means America means
happiness means the beginning of my life
when I started when I was in fifth grade
they asked us who do you want to be when
you grow up and everybody wrote
policeman asked for not all sorts of
different stuff and I wrote the owner of
the New York Jets and that was the first
time I said it publicly and I've said it
basically to everybody I've met since
and then obviously over the last 10
years
as more people got to know me it's a
part of my story it's very important
it's actually very similar to the nice
gentleman from Argentina it you have to
be self-aware
for me entrepreneurship and building
businesses has always been my happiness
lemonade when I was five to being right
here with you today at 43 so for me
wanting to buy the New York Jets is very
important because it's a goal that
allows me to play for a very long time
and that is what brings me happiness the
process as a matter of fact I've already
made a video maybe five or six years ago
that I have saved and it's the video
that I'm gonna share with the world the
day I buy the New York Jets and in the
video I tell everybody that today is a
sad day not a happy day because
something that I've been chasing for a
very long time has come to a conclusion
and then I make a joke about winning a
Super Bowl and something like that but
nonetheless it's important for me not
because you shoot for the moon and you
land in the mountains it's important to
me because it represents a process I
want everybody here to love what they do
in the process not necessarily the stuff
that comes along you know money fame you
know vacations clothes I want them to
love the game not the stuff for me
having a big goal lets me play longer
got it got it thank you thank you last
couple questions so another thing that
we talked a lot about here is the
struggle especially for intrapreneurs
now we have to deal with that you always
talk about hustling you know and what
keeps you up at night today like it's
you're a successful guy still but you
still have some struggles right yeah but
but that's what I signed up for like I
don't understand when people are trying
to aspire to be unbelievably happy
and unbelievably wealthy it
should be hard like every day's hard I
landed here from these three flights to
get here and immediately I get Wi-Fi and
there's four texts from clients problem
problem problem problem it should be
hard you know my struggles today are
100% outside the framework of my
business for me that's my safe place and
I accept that there's going to be tough
things as a matter of fact this is funny
I didn't do it on this trip but
sometimes when I fly and I have to fill
out custom forms when it says occupation
I write firefighter that's how I feel an
entrepreneur is you're always ready for
another fire whether it's two o'clock in
the morning or 9:30 you have to be ready
and I don't struggle with that because
I've been practicing it my whole life
which is why I fear when people try to
become entrepreneurs because it's cool
now I'm worried about that because it's
very hard and if you're not used to
losing it I lose every day every single
day I lose and unless you're good at
that you will not like entrepreneurship
and how do you you know what slap you
can glad to join class there's something
in there you know where my mind just
when I apologize when my mind just went
is it's funny where I just went as we
just finished at out here about the clap
I said I said to myself I said it's hard
to lose when you already lost
I'm already pot committed to the game I
know what I signed up for you can't lose
when you already think you're losing
everybody thinks entrepreneurship I'm
gonna start the next [ __ ] uber and be
a billionaire
no you're not and the second you
understand that is but it gets good and
now we run multiple companies most of
them are very successful how do you
prioritize your life how to balance
death and all you don't like the word
balance but juggling
and being okay the reason most people
aren't doing what I do is I'm okay
juggling and letting something fall
because I don't give I was juggling
right now eggs and you were all
impressed and I dropped an egg and you
all said I wouldn't care it's part of
the game so for me it's easy to do the
wine and the business and the sneakers
and all this stuff I'm doing because if
something fails people will tweet about
it people will write about it but I
won't hear it
what's so important and the one thing I
wish for all of you and was earlier to
the parenting question as you can
imagine especially if you don't know me
and you just discovered me and you see
how people are talking about me you
could imagine how easy it is to get high
when people say that you're changing
their life and all this unbelievable but
it's very funny for me I don't when I
hear the beautiful things that are said
to me I think about Sasha I think about
my parents I I think man they did a good
job I'm the product of them I'm the
product of immigrants and struggling and
good parents so when I hear nice things
I don't get high but that's a very good
thing because when people say the
reverse in my comments or negative
things I don't get low when you become
detached detached from either positive
or negative comments you win the reason
so many of you struggle is you like the
compliments when people say you're
pretty you like the compliments when
people say you're smart you like the
compliments when you're dressed good you
came about a good idea you scored a goal
you made a couple you like that so when
but now you get used to the feedback so
then when somebody says you're [ __ ] you
believe that too
I don't believe either I hear nothing
it's super quiet up here
it's super [ __ ] quiet up here
you